good morning John so a couple of months
ago I posted a video of me making
headquarter fish art for project for
awesome donors and there were a bunch of
people helping me right here this person
is Monica tranelle the reason she's
there is that she's running for congress
and I wanted to maybe talk to her if I
could and so I emailed her and she said
let's have coffee and I said let's let's
make fish so that was the first time I
met Monica trannell but over the last
few months I've met her a few more times
mostly because I said I would like to
rent out some rooms and interview you in
them publicly time for some honesty I
don't know how to be a person with a big
audience who also doesn't like the way
that the world is obviously different
people have different views on the way
that the world should be but I have mine
I don't like a lot of the way things are
we've had an audience of some kind for a
long time I remember celebrating the
election of Barack Obama with you like
the first one while we were on tour I
think we've been doing this for a while
but most of what we've done over the
years has been pretty nationally focused
which makes a lot of sense because our
audience is isn't even National it's
International so focusing local like
very few people here are going to have
the opportunity to vote for Monica
trannell some of you though and you
better because she's great but in
general I've started to feel like the
Relentless focus on the biggest possible
scope of all conversations that always
being National isn't good I live in
Montana a state that Trump won by 16 in
2020 and by 20 in 2016 but in 2016 we
also elected a Democratic governor and
we have a Democratic senator John tester
who is amazing I don't think anybody
would expect that I think most people
don't know that because it doesn't fit
into the national narrative we are a
very red state that does a lot of pretty
blue things we can only really tell
ourselves simple stories when we don't
let a lot of data in now I understand
not letting a lot of data and it's very
complicated and we want to tell simple
stories so that people will believe the
thing but these simple stories are
starting to Rend
Rend so when Joe Biden's team emailed me
and they were like do you want to come
to the White House to hang out with the
president I was like yeah I do but I
really only have so much time this year
and I'm focusing a lot on what's going
on in my community I want to think about
that I want to be aware of that I want
to know how amazing Monica trannell is
and she is amazing and if she doesn't
win it's going to be because of a focus
on National politics like her opponent
isn't very popular but Democrats are
unpopular she's put like fifty thousand
miles on her minivan traveling across
what is one of the largest districts in
America talking to people in 16 counties
and two tribal Nations and she keeps
telling me every chance she gets that
she just wishes that I and everybody
else could see the America that she sees
when she goes out there to listen to
people what those conversations are
telling her is that people are a lot
more complex than they get credit for
and that seems wrong to me but her
perspective is actually backed up by the
research which shows that people see
themselves as being pretty 60 40 on
stuff but they see their opponents as
being very 100 zero on everything in
fact there's a lot of stuff that doesn't
fit into broader narratives and because
it doesn't we just don't ever think
about it or talk about it that true fact
feels unintuitive to me but it feels
intuitive to Monica because she's the
one out there doing the work that is why
we hire other people to be our leaders
because they get to know more about this
than we ever will so that we can focus
on doing the other thing the problems
are very big but this country is messy
and it is Led in a lot of different ways
and the ballot that I get is a local
ballot with local things on it so this
election with the time that I had I
decided to go local and I feel really
good about it John I'll see you on
Tuesday and if you can vote in this
election you're going to go local too if
you aren't sure how to vote where you
are or whether you're registered Etc you
can check out youtube.com how to vote in
every state and I will tell you
everything you need to know